this is a training exercise at a Latvian
army base not far from the Russian
border soldiers here are aware of the
overwhelming Russian presence nearby
oscar's korsakoff's is a professional
soldier he says he's ready to join the
battle for his country since the crisis
in Ukraine erupted many here view Russia
as an enemy who might attack Latvia and
the entire Baltic region
korsakoff's volunteered to serve since
there's no conscription in the country
I've been in the Army for nine months I
have the opportunity to advance I could
for instance become the commander of a
small army unit I'm going to stick with
this for a bit and see what comes of it
his first target practice doesn't work
out so well just four out of ten shots
on target of course the cops isn't happy
at all he says it was our camera that
made him nervous
this new generation of Latvian soldiers
grew up in a post-soviet world in an
independent Latvia in school he learned
English as a first foreign language
instead of Russian the infantrymen have
the same modern assault rifles as used
by the German armed forces but the rest
of their equipment leaves a lot to be
desired
the Latvian infantry doesn't have enough
vehicles that could be used to deploy
soldiers in case of an emergency
that role would fall to Latvia's
partners in NATO commander cost bars
Putin's says he would count on the North
Atlantic Alliance to come to the aid of
Latvia in accordance with article 5 of
the NATO treaty 25 of course is
important for us that's our guarantees
for our security and defence we are not
probably fully capable of facing big
threats which could appear in our
territory and we of course that's why we
realize and need cooperation that could
for example include a Rapid Reaction
Force as several NATO members have
proposed NATO leaders are expected to
agree to set up such a force at its
summit in Wales beginning Thursday it's
a plan the commanding general of the
Latvian army supports I would say the
most important task for NATO is the
ability to act almost immediately
reaction so letter supports any any any
plans which should increase speed of
moving around troops any place in NATO
territory now all the politicians need
to do is make a decision and oscar's
korsakoff's infantry units might perhaps
then belong to the new multinational
force back at target practice
korsakoff's has vastly improved on the
second round this time he scored a 10
out of 10